good morning everyone glad you could
make it so my name is Miro I work for
scheme technologies in London and the
slides for this talk so I tried quite
hard to make everything pretty large so
I should be readable but in case you
can't see it at the back here's all the
slides on github I just saw that there
for a second
right so the point of this talk is
broadly speaking machine learning but
not so much the learning part of it but
more about what it is that you're
learning from and to set the context a
little bit because I imagine some of you
would not be from a technical background
I'll give a very quick introduction to
what machine learning is in about 45
seconds so the job here is to get the
machine to observe some input data some
information and then give you an output
another output should be something
useful for example if you've got
something like a user by the name of
arrow that's me making a 14-pound
transaction late late at night on a
Friday in a pub in London that's
probably okay if you're a credit card
company looking to remove fraudulent
transactions this one is about as good
as they come that's fine that's what I
do on Fridays at the same time if you
get a 1400 pound transaction in Milan in
the Versace store that's probably not me
so you definitely want to be able to
automate the process of telling between
a fraudulent transaction and one that's
all right
and what we want to do is to get the
machine to do this completely
automatically because if you're
operating at scale you're not able to do
it manually here's another example which
is related to something we'll talk about
later in the talk if you're a medical
company and you're looking to kind of
connect people to the right doctor and
you get a patient who comes in and says
hi if you a sharp pain in my chest what
you want the machine to say is this
person needs to see a cardiologist and
you need to see them right now this
seems like an urgent thing right
so machine learning is basically a
combination of having that data that
says if someone complains of chest pains
when they run for more than 30 seconds
then they need to see a cardiologist
it's that information and then it's the
algorithms that get the machine to learn
something useful from that information
this talk is specifically about the data
so you can you can go two ways really to
to achieve the task one is you spend the
month doing what you'd call unsupervised
machine learning where basically a human
will not be aiding the machine so the
machine is just sitting there you've got
the mental data but no one is telling it
what it needs to produce given a
particular input but the good news is
you don't need any examples like this so
no one needs to tell the Machine that if
someone complains of a sharp pain that
means cardiologist now which is great
because it means less work for you but
that takes forever and it's really
really difficult to do well so the
common knowledge is instead of doing a
month of supervised clever machine sorry
unsupervised clever machine learning
what you should do is get a bunch of
people and spend the week building up a
big a big set of examples and then train
the machine by example pretty much the
same way you get trained in the scope
now the question I want to ask here is
how do we get good examples because as
you know the common knowledge in machine
learning is garbage in garbage out if
you're providing rubbish data then your
machine will just learn that rubbish and
you end up with nothing useful at the
end and a lot of money invested into
nothing so the question how does garbage
get created it it's the process of what
it is that you should be doing or
shouldn't be doing to make sure that the
data that you're feeding into your
clever algorithm is good then if it's
not regardless of how much time and how
clever you are with your training you're
not going to get good results so I'm
particularly concerned with one way of
getting data and that's the manual way
so you sit down you bring in a few
humans you show them an example in say
right what should the machine say if I
give this to the machine
we're not concerned with can a
large-scale data collection the kind of
NSA thing you might hear or be worried
about that that has its own interesting
challenges probably a separate talk in
its own right just to mention a few of
the issues just making sure that you can
actually transmit and store huge amounts
of information is a pretty difficult
task in itself so what I'm going to be
talking about is how you're dealing with
humans how you get them to give you good
data and to do that
I'll focus on two case studies the first
one is about word embeddings and one is
about symptom recognition in medical
data that's both a natural language
engineering the kind of thing that I've
done this first one is based in my own
PhD and second case study is based on
the PhD my friend sasha over there in
the front row so if you want to know a
lot more about that go talk to him after
the talk
so okay first case study is worth
embedding so a bit of context again the
the task here is to get to represent
words as a vector so that's a very
popular thing to do recently because the
distance between those vectors turns out
to be very indicative of certain
semantic properties no one entirely
understands what exactly is going on
there but it seems to be very useful for
a lot of that so people are really eager
and from a purely kind of computational
perspective you can do it completely
unsupervised you just download Wikipedia
run the latest code overnight and you
get this magical representation where
captain dog end up very similar ideally
unless you've messed something up with
your pre-processing and democracy ends
up being very dissimilar so you've
captured some semantics there and that's
completely for free all you need is just
some text no human input whatsoever so
the question I was interested in for my
PhD is how do you know if you've done a
good job so there's obviously many ways
you can build those vectors which one's
better and the way people typically
dealt with that in the past and in the
past I mean starting from the 1960s up
until a year ago or well three the
typical way to do it is to get humans
show them pairs of words and ask them to
give
a similarity score so if someone says
cat dog you should get something high
ORAC 80% what is that's what most people
would go for and if you get cat in
democracy you should get a low number so
the way we and the way we work out
whether the machine is doing well or
rather the automated model as well is we
correlate that with human scores that we
get in a psycho linguistic laboratory so
we get humans these are the scores here
on the left then we get the machine to
produce similarity scores for the exact
same right there and if these scores
much well then we know we've built a
good model at least that's the theory so
this model here would not be especially
good because it seems to think cut and
democracy are very similar of some
reason and by the way it is a completely
made-up number so don't read too much
into them so we get humans to give us
the numbers on the left and then we get
the Machine to give us the numbers on
the right so what I'm interested in is
how do we get the humans to give us
those numbers in such a way that they
are actually reliable and useful for
evaluation oh and I had a picture for
something that I just said so if you
just cut it this course that you get
between between the humans in the
machine if you get a nice tight fit like
this then you've got a pretty good model
and if you get up just a point cloud'
completely shapeless then you know
you're not doing very well so here's a
few questions here that you need to ask
yourself when you're bringing those
people in and asking them to provide you
with similarity scores and each of these
questions are things that I should have
thought of advance when I was in my PhD
but I didn't actually
so things ended up being a lot more
difficult than they should've been so
the first question is do you actually
know what is it that you're asking
people to do like is the task very
clearly defined so can you
we all have an intuitive understanding
of what word similarity means because
you know cat the dog they sound pretty
similar right but if you actually try to
explain in a lot of detail to someone if
you try to pin all the corner cases it
turns out it's very difficult so some
people think that similarity is because
of some kind of topical relatedness so
cats and dogs
the kind of topically related because
they both bet but they also have
physical similarities four legs tails
they're flurry some people would say
that you've got things like cooking and
rice which are also similar because you
do both in the kitchen and they kind of
food-related but some people disagree
with that if got antonyms such as good
and bad
some people think these are very similar
because they they serve the same purpose
in the sentence anyway you can say this
is good you could also say this is bad
and it will teach a perfectly
grammatical sentence but it also
expresses the exact opposite thing so
it's kind of the opposite so if you try
and pin down this corner cases it ends
up being very difficult and there's this
popular academic data set called Watson
three five three
I'll give the references at the end and
they got 13 people and asked them to
rate words and the scores they got for
tiger and cats
range from anywhere from five to nine on
a ten-point scale so even for something
which would be very obvious like cat and
tiger you just get very very different
scores and that's because the whole
concept of similarity is very badly
defined even if you could define your
task well so certain tasks are just very
difficult to do for a human so this is
the subjectivity involved for example if
you're dealing with something like
detecting sarcasm in text that's really
really hard to do without any facial
visual cues and especially hard to do
out of context if you just get the text
that says yeah nice or sorry rather yes
nice in the absence of any voice cues
and intonation you can't really tell if
someone's being sarcastic or not so if a
human can do it how can we expect them
to give you that information of what
they're doing so we can train the
machine so what can we do with that
first the most important stage that
people know who are not never but not
very frequent to think about is actually
having clear instructions and starting
with those very very early and writing
everything down even if you're the one
doing the annotation so especially in
the beginning you don't want to
and God find people ask them to do work
for you you do one round yourself to get
a feel for the task obviously even if
you're doing that yourself you should
write everything down first for
reference because if you come back to
that three weeks later you're not going
to know what you had in mind three weeks
earlier but also because writing things
down helps clarify it so ideally then
you'd get someone else to proofread your
text you give them your instructions and
you ask them to tell you what they think
you meant because if someone interprets
your instructions differently this all
will the annotations that you're going
to work with if you can obviously you
can you should try and make your task
simpler so if your business case is such
that you can't get away with it there's
no point in having a really really fine
grained task if you can get away with
something that's easier and I have that
picture just as an excuse to have a cat
than Superman Chihuahua in the side but
if if your business wants to tell apart
cat from dogs all you have to do is to
get humans to tell apart the cat and all
these dogs I don't actually care about
distinction between these three kinds of
dogs I don't think I could actually name
these three breeds so if I were to be
brought in as an annotator and someone
told me well this is a cat but I have no
idea what type of cat it is and these
are three different breeds and I have no
idea what they are I guess this is a
two-hour but that's about as far as my
knowledge goes and I'm not that unusual
actually it turns out someone tried to
do this and it's very very hard so my
point is don't get your people to tell
apart different dog breeds if all you
care about for your business case is cat
versus dog maybe that's just good enough
so the next question you have to worry
about is whether you have quality
controls in place so there's many ways
to do quality control and the most
common mistake people make is not having
any of those in place it's really not
that crucial how exactly you check that
what you're getting is good but please
you should be checking one of the
possible ways of doing it and I will
just mention a few ways quickly is inter
annotate the agreement and that's a
number that measures how well your
different people doing the same task
agree with each other it's basically the
same
we had earlier where we're measuring the
agreement between the human and the
machine in this case we're getting to
humans asking them to do the same job if
they give us the same output then we
know that what we're getting is good
although you do have to be careful
because they might just agree by chance
if they're randomly clicking they there
is a small probability that they will
get the same result another option is to
actually sit down and do some of the
work yourself make sure that it's very
very good quality do it a few times
triple check everything and then every
now and then show those examples to
humans and check if they're doing well
if they match your output then they're
doing all right another example is to
just insert random noise in the data and
see if humans notice the cuts probably
the most effective and cheapest quality
control to implement and that kind of
what Stack Overflow does so they have
this review dialog where if someone
suggested an edit to a post you can see
the disc that says what's being changed
in the question and then a human needs
to look at that and say yeah this is a
valid edit that improves the question so
they'll show you is this the thing on
the left is the original question the
thing on the right is the new edited
question and you need to say whether
this one's okay or not and every now and
then every ten questions or so they'll
pop something up on screen which looks
like this I don't know if you can read
it at the back but it's just completely
random text inserted in the middle of a
valid question and what they're checking
there is to see if you're paying
attention and if you don't they just
tell you well please come back when
you're actually ready to help the
community rather than just clicking
buttons here so that's a very very nice
and cheap way of catching people were
just there for the 17 pounds that you're
going to pay them for a month worth of
work so the point of all college
controls is you probably want to be
running them continuously so every no
ideally after every little micro task
the human does and you should watch for
kind of just random errors maybe
sometimes the person missed clicks that
that's not too big of a problem but if
they're systematically making the same
mistakes you should probably look into
your own instructions
if you have multiple people consistently
making the same error then that's
probably something to do with what
you've asked them to do and then
misunderstanding so it's your fault most
likely it helps if you're in the same
room with those people so you can
actually talk to them and work out why
they're making that mistake and
obviously it's it it's not something
that you'd like to do but if they're
making mistakes all the time just you
should throw away the day then start
from scratch because it's garbage it's
not going to do you any good downstream
another question is how much data are
you going to need so obviously certain
algorithms improve with with more data
and the typical learning curve is
something like that
as you start throwing in more later the
model gets better so if you see that
there is a clear upwards trend then
obviously there is a point in carrying
on but that gets very expensive so what
you should be doing is looking at this
learning curve and double-checking that
adding more data and spending more time
and effort into gathering more data will
be useful rather than just waste time
and a small aside here on the ethics of
crowdsourcing so very often what people
do is go to Amazon they have this
fantastic tool called Mechanical Turk
I'll talk about that a bit more in a
minute and you'd offer tasks can you pay
something like once one u.s. sent a
click and what people very often forget
is that a lot of these annotators
actually doing it as a full-time job
date they rely on that to make a living
and feed their families so just pay them
properly treat them respectfully instead
of just randomly throwing away their
data because if you throw away their
data they don't get paid for it so they
go hungry at night and especially be
careful with the good ones because
they're very very hard to find so if you
find the conscientious person who's
actually doing understanding your task
and doing it consistently well they're
really hard to find so you should have a
good relationship with them it's ok so
here's the case study that's based on
South Shores PhD so again talk to him
about the details of this the tasks that
we want to do here is if you have a note
so these are these a doctor's note so
normally when you go through your doctor
what they'll do is after you leave there
type some notes into your medical record
that says what you talked about what
your problems are what you need to do
later so what you might see in a typical
note this is a made-up example by the
way because you're not actually allowed
to look at those is abdominal pain due
to tonsillitis and what we want to find
out here is that the symptom is
abdominal pain and the potential causes
acute bacterial tonsillitis and we want
to be able to do that automatically to
help doctors identify possible diseases
that they might have missed they're
underfunded so that sounds very easy but
it's actually not and there's a few
issues here the first one is that
doctors are actually very very busy so
the moment you leave the room they have
about one minute to write down
everything that you talked about so what
you end up with is something that's even
worse than Twitter so there's a ton of
dipoles lots and lots of dipoles they'll
use non-standard punctuation I have seen
cases where they just go or
forward-slash instead of post-op because
why not I can do that and there's a lot
of terminology with this be done unless
you have unless you're a medical
professional you're not going to know
what what this means so it is very very
messy messy to the point where you can't
even just find the boundaries between
the words because you never know where
this whole thing here peon acute is a
single thing with a slash in it the same
way as n/a is a single word or it's two
words so even the most fundamental
natural language processing task quite
breaking words down gets very very
difficult in medical text so the
question is okay right we're going to be
bringing people in and we're going to be
asking them to annotate this data so we
can train the Machine to find symptoms
now can anyone do it you can't just get
a guy off the street and ask them to do
this for you because it needs to be done
by a trained physician and they don't
like to do that very much they prefer to
practice medicine and heal people so we
need to work very very hard to actually
find those people convinced
them to come work with you and not just
for an hour because they'll get bored
extremely quickly you need to convince
them to come in consistently because
once you've trained them up you need to
be able to use that knowledge that they
have accumulated the next problem is
they're typically not experts in
linguistics so what you tell them is
write a symptom needs to be a fully
qualified noun phrase and they go sorry
a noun what and of course I don't blame
them I don't expect anyone unless they
are trained linguist to know what the
noun phrase is or 10 you know they do
some annotation and you suddenly go yeah
your standard deviation is quite high
over time and you know something's not
quite right here so it's very very hard
to talk to people if you don't have a
common vocabulary to the point where you
can't even explain to them what it is
that you're asking them to do and what
you end up with is is cases like that
some people go well obviously pain is
the symptom here it's irrelevant that
it's abdominal and someone might say
well we have here it's bacterial
tonsillitis I can see that it's
bacterial it's irrelevant is it acute
because that's a subjective thing you do
you don't seem particularly odd to me
right so that's the symptom acute is not
a part of the symptom someone might say
well it's clearly acute the fact that
it's bacterial is yet to be confirmed
because we haven't done a test it could
be viral
but it seems quite inflamed to me so I
reckon it's cute so the point here is
even if you're doing quality controls
it's not as easy to actually measure
agreement in the word in the word
similarity that we talked about earlier
it's quite easy you just do that for if
you have a tight fit then it's a good
fit every statistical package will have
a Pearson correlation implementation
really easy in this case with with these
massive chunks that could be used that
could overlap they could be have could
have gaps in them they could be missing
altogether it becomes much harder to
even understand if you're humans are
doing well because you don't know
whether what two people are giving you
is the same or rather you can put a
number to that it's not a simple
correlation anymore so
if you want to kind of read some more
there's a 20 paper 20 pager here by arts
dining ratio and then social or
therapist about this in his PhD it is
quite an interesting problem but it
involves a lot of tricky corner cases
and a ton of rows to write down the the
third question is if you if you're
bringing people in and asking into the
work for you you need to provide them
with some software so in the word
similarity case a text editor is good
enough so you just go CatDog please fill
in the gap so you don't need any
specialty stooling here you need
something that would enable them to
select symptoms select whether they're
symptoms or also suspected symptoms and
so on and so on so you need some kind of
special software that software obviously
has to be bug free because no one wants
to use buggy software if you're dealing
with medical data you cannot use the
cloud providers that's a big no-no it
needs to it's extremely sensitive you
need to make sure that you can host it
yourself which means a lot more DevOps
work for you you need to have data
security like if a particular data is
only allowed to access the small subset
of data they shouldn't be able to see
everything else because that's private
that tooling ideally would let you do
quality controls and they do it
automatically and all the time and
purely from a practical point of view
you want the piece of software that's
easy to install if you're getting
something off the shelf or you want
something that's easy to write if you're
doing it yourself because that adds up
very quickly you could easily spend
weeks here just writing software without
getting any data and from a people's
point of view you definitely need
something that's easy to use especially
if you're going crowdsourcing through
Amazon
you'd be surprised by how many people
there don't really know what
right-clicking means so the bar needs to
be very very low the tool needs to be
very simple and it needs to not get in
the way it should enabling people rather
than getting in their way and making it
hard for them and one typical example
that you've seen is you see a lot in
these those is once you annotate
something you can't go back so if you
miss click well that's it you don't get
paid for that and again bug free
no one wants to use it if it's buggy so
there's many tools like that
there's CrowdFlower there's Mechanical
Turk by Amazon the screenshots down here
is from Pratt which stands for rapid
annotation or something like that or you
could write something in-house each of
those has its own issues
so CrowdFlower and Mechanical Turk they
do a lot of the work for you they find
annotated but you have to set up the
task so there's a little bit of a steep
learning curve initially but when when
sasha was using it that was like three
or four years ago
this took easily a week to install
because it was a mixture of PHP and
Python running on Apache behind the
firewall because you obviously can't put
it on Amazon it has to be on your
private network so the whole thing is
just a very very unpleasant experience
it takes a whole week just to get
started and the final kind of set of
issues that you're going to be
encountering if when you're dealing with
people is just people issues and that my
controversial claim is that if you can
find a good annotator
who's giving you decent data all the
time they're going to contribute more to
the success of your project than your
entire team of programmers simply
because that data is pure gold you run
if it's good quality easy data you just
run of a simplest machine learning
algorithm on top of it and you get value
into trouble you can you can have an
entire team of data scientists doing
things they're not going to get anywhere
because you can't learn from random
noise so if you find a good person just
make sure you build a good relationship
with them even be friends or at least
treat them with treat them with respect
it helps very much to be in the same
room then you'd be able to to work out
if they have any misconceptions about
what you're asking them to do but it
also helps you to learn about the
problem so when you're there and you
tell them all finally a noun phrase and
then they can't identify a noun phrase
in your sentence well maybe you don't
really need the noun phrase maybe you
just need to word it differently or
maybe you don't even want nouns at all
maybe you just want verbs so if you
don't understand what the task is you're
not going to get anywhere it's very
useful if you have a tutorial because
people
forget especially if that's not their
area of expertise so doctors come in
they do the training they get pretty
good at it in a couple of days and then
they go on holiday for six weeks then
when they come back again they don't
remember what the noun phrase it so
you'd have to have a good mechanism to
make sure that they don't forget or if
they do they need to be retrained and of
course there's the usual day-to-day
things like oh sorry I'm not feeling
that well I can't come in today well yes
but I was I was kind of counting on you
to come in today because I need your
data to do my next round of experiment
or I have seen cases where people say oh
could I maybe just work from home and
when when they work from home their data
is completely random they just look out
the window and Stroke their cap
whereas when they come into your office
and the supervision they do a fantastic
job so that is annoyingly two things
that can a management issues that you
have to worry about and they always mean
they always mean that you end up under
estimating the complexity of getting
some labeled attics you always think oh
yeah and always I'm just bringing three
guards they'll do it in a day it doesn't
take a day it takes a week or a month so
a quick note here on crowdsourcing I
have brought it up very quickly
repeatedly you get all the same issues
as above and on top of that you get a
whole lot of new things so you get
people in in India for example or not
necessarily in India India is probably a
bad example but you let's say you're
labeling data in the English and you get
a bunch of people from Eastern Europe
whose command of English is not so
fantastic maybe for UK starts ok but if
you want medical data you definitely
want a native English speaker Lib and
also a doctor doing your data so you
need to be you need to be filtering and
obviously when they are not in the same
room as you they're somewhere you know
anywhere on the globe you can't know who
they are so you end up with a lot of
people who just randomly click they get
paid a bit of money for every click so
they want to do it faster and be done
with it to make some more money and
there's also a kind of a learning curve
so that is the learning curve for them
because they need to rely on your very
short instructions on CrowdFlower
instead of you them coming in and having
a three-hour conversation with you about
all the subtleties of finding noun
phrases so right in summary it's very
very good if you know your own problem
domain so if you don't understand what
what you're trying to do then you can't
get others to understand it and do it
for you inevitably as you start talking
to people you will find that there's
some assumptions that you made that are
not justified so it's very very hard but
you should be able to just let go if you
find out that you've done something
completely the wrong way you should just
go right bin it start over if you can
sorry not if you can but you should be
monitoring quality ideally continuously
otherwise you end up with nothing that's
good for you and if you are
crowdsourcing just be extra careful cuz
you can't control who's clicking what
you end up with lots of data but it
might be even noisier than usual alright
that's it
[Applause]
question is how much do you pay for
click the answer is I don't actually use
Amazon for that because there were few
reasons that I've mentioned already so
people typically pay with anywhere
between 1 and 10 cents depending on the
complexity so something like a word
similarity task it's a very very low
friction you can do 60 of those a minute
so 1 cent is quite justified if it's a
more complex task like there's an entire
receipt can you transcribe every single
character on it then you obviously
should pay more it helps very much if
you do the job yourself and I'm going to
think about how much you can make if
that was your job and if the answer is 2
dollars an hour then it's probably too
little there's a question at the back
there sorry I can't hear you can you
speak up huh so it's about the first
case study and I hope you have actually
used the word to work model or or
doctorate model for for generating the
word embeddings yeah so in that case the
similarity between of course the cat and
dog is fine for example also in the
vertex model you get good and bad as
similar ones so how do you make people
understand that good and bad are kind of
similar because in those case were two
ik actually performed better because
that's how it works but people cannot
understand how were to acquire so they
may not evaluate good and better similar
ones but this is kind of independent of
worth to Veck so the fact that good and
bad end up being similar it's just a
side effect to the fact that they appear
in the same context so where to Veck is
learning to make them similar but the
question here was a more fundamental one
that's completely independent from any
particular algorithm so it should they
be similar or should they not it should
be similar because that's how it works
and if were to actually works in an
ideal condition its people should name
it similar right
I hope they if they actually evaluate it
as false oh and then it means that word
to word is not working good but what if
I want to know if we're to Veck is
working well right suppose I'm Tomas
make over five years ago and I've just
built where to work and I don't know so
if you basically told me that because
that's how work Tuvok works that's the
right result but if I've just built it
and some stuff has come out how do I
know if it's working or not
so re-evaluating the model or are
evaluating the the the target idea of
what you are working on well ideally
those should be the same so the model
should be a model of semantics so what I
want to be evaluating is if it's
learning useful word representations so
if I as a human belief that good and bad
are dissimilar
then the model should be learning that
as well now okay thank you so come back
come back after this yes yes when you
annotate data if there are certain
thresholds you're aiming for awhile
annotating it because you guys in for
100% precision on your training data so
do you have this threshold and the
second one is assuming it's below the
threshold do you adapt your models
according to the precision of the
training data so when you when you say
precision do you mean agreement or
quality or quality of it let's say it's
a deterministic task and as you want it
and you want it to be well labeled so
out of all the labels ninety-five
percent can be right
is there such a threshold you would have
well yeah but it's not a number so
you're probably not going to like this
answer it's as well as you can get away
with depending on what you're doing so
if your business case allows you to work
with crappy data which is not well I
shouldn't say crappy you know what they
say don't let perfect get in the way of
good so if your data is imperfect and
it's 96 percent and 96 turns out to be
good enough for your task then perfect
you've achieved what you set out to do
it doesn't have to be at at 100
sometimes 70% ends up okay it's still
much better than not having anything
there sorry so the question is will it
affect your model yes obviously rubbish
data will affect your model but if the
model ends up being good enough in the
end it's fine
so normally in academic literature would
say that good agreement is about
correlation of point six or above which
isn't actually that much but if it works
for you hey I mean so show how much was
your agreement do you remember
so 0.87 which is pretty high still
that the models that ended up being
built on that had a lot of issues so the
problem there wasn't so much with the
agreement it's big it's the sparsity of
the data and the real complexity of the
task so I guess there it was more about
not having enough good quality data the
data that he had was good it's just it's
physically impossible within the space
of a PhD to get much more than that
thank you